[Applause]
welcome to the TUC our Parliament for
working people represented
we've got represented here in the hall
today millions of workers who keep the
wheels of this country turning all they
ask in return is respect and fair pay
and if it takes strike action so be it
we stand with you
so let's hear it for our incredible care
assistants and NHS staff Rail and bus
workers dedicated posters come on Prison
officers
call center staff refuse workers stock
workers teachers University lecturers
civil servants and many more
[Applause]
conference these are decent people who
are honest and hardworking but according
to Liz truss
British workers are layabouts lacking
graft skill and application the Prime
Minister believes that Britain's poor
productivity is down to the poor
performance of workers
it's a bit Rich from OPM whose own
performance crashed the country
she didn't even turn up for work
yesterday
and since her disastrous debut we've had
more u-turns from her than a
malfunctioning Sat Nav
and all this all this after 12 long
years of conservative governments that
have slashed burned and ripped off this
country something rotten well the Sun
was shining the tourists didn't mend the
roof they nicked the lead off it
so let's let's have a reminder of what's
happened under Tory governments which
country has the worst investment in the
G7
the UK which country has the worst wages
growth in the G7 don't need to tell
workers this one the UK and which
country has the worst economic growth in
the G7 you've guessed it the UK that's
your record prime minister that's the
country your party has been running for
the past 12 years
now to be fair under the conservatives
some things are growing
CEO pay up corporate profits up Bankers
bonuses up and look what else the cost
of mortgages NHS waiting lists ambulance
waiting times child poverty food banks
up up up
that means more kids going to bed hungry
more families afraid to put the heating
on
but there is a real plan for growth
trade unions want a growing economy that
works for working people high investment
High skills and high wages decent work
so workers don't need to go on strike to
defend their pay and we want a strong
society that comes with growth fairly
shared a well-funded NHS schools public
services a safety net to help us all in
a crisis no one growing up and no one
growing old in poverty a safe secure
welcoming society and more than that a
con a country of culture music football
books and Brilliant TV
for over a decade now the TUC has made
that case for investment for r d for
Innovation for skills to make things
here in Britain to meet the challenge of
Net Zero with good green jobs and to
harness the big gains of new tech for
all of us
we need an economy that rewards work not
wealth
but under
but under the conservatives working
people have got poorer while
shareholders have got richer we're in
the longest squeeze on real wages since
Napoleonic times and if ministers and
employers keep hammering pay packets at
the same rate UK workers are on course
to suffer two decades 20 years of lost
living standards
over the next three years alone real
earnings are set to Fall by another four
thousand pounds we have got to stop the
rot families can't afford to tighten
their belts anymore they're at Breaking
Point
just look at that disastrous mini budget
only a month ago
and I say this to Liz Truss your budget
wasn't pro-growth it was pro-greed
tax cuts for the rich with no plan for
growth at all that's why the markets got
spooked that's why the economy Tanked
the PM may have dumped quasi-quarting
and is now hiding behind Jeremy Hunt or
maybe under a desk who knows but she
can't duck this one we don't trust her
government with our economy and
livelihoods are on the line
now some say Liz trusts must go
I think they're wrong
this whole rotten Tory government must
go
the tour is a toxic it's time for change
we need a general election now
we know who really creates wealth in
this country and it's not the hedge fund
managers who made amidst by betting on
the pound crashing the real wealth
creators are the people of this country
now Jeremy Hunt may be the new face at
number 11 but it's the same old story
lift the cap on Bankers bonuses drive
down workers pay handouts for the
wealthy and big business cuts to
Universal Credit and benefits give to
the rich take from everyone else Robin
Hood in reverse
Sherwood Forest fracked
[Applause]
working people are not fooled by
trickle-down economics it's the same old
Tory money trick austerity means NHS
waiting lists grow and businesses go
bust when workers get money they spend
it when the rich get money they offshore
it so I have a message for Liz Tross
working people are proud of the jobs we
do we work hard we work the longest
hours in Europe yet thanks to your
party's 12 years in government millions
are struggling to make ends meet we
don't need lectures on working harder
this country needs a proper plan for
fairer Greener growth
the prime minister
should answer another important question
if you really care about hard graft and
performance how come you gave Jacob
Reese smog a job
a man best known for lying horizontal on
the commons benches who aims to make
life even harder on the shop floor
he wants workers rights that came from
the EU stripped from the statute book
important rights like holiday pay time
off for mums and dads and safe limits on
working time
but the minister for the 19th century
needs to wake up
the Tec has just asked people who voted
conservative in the last election what
they think the government should do
81 of Tory voters say protect our rights
at work and more and more we demand
action to tackle corporate gangsters
never forget piano
a prime example of everything wrong with
UK labor laws loyal crew sacked without
a second thought Shameless bosses
admitting they'd broken the law and
ministers letting them get away with it
worse rights at work won't rebuild
Britain Britain only does well when
working people do well and we demand a
new deal a better deal for working
people
the truth is from toll puddle onwards
The Establishment has always seen
workers organizing as a threat and yes
we are we are a threat we're a threat to
casino capitalism we're a threat to the
notion that you can divide workers and
we are a threat to exploitation and low
pay
so just when the citizens of this
country are in despair when key workers
kids are going to school with holes in
their shoes and young families are
worried sick about the mortgage this
government this government's top
priority is attacking the right to
strike to make it harder to win fair pay
a cynical effort to distract from the
chaos that they have caused
but I say this if ministers want to pick
a fight with us we are more than ready
[Applause]
I give them notice we've already taken
legal counsel we know that you're in
breach of international law and trade
deals that enshrine labor standards so
read my lips we will see you in court
[Applause]
now this winter we all know looks set to
be a tough one we Face an emergency made
in Downing Street and the lights could
go off all over Britain even with Energy
prices capped average bills are set to
double other costs have gone through the
roof child care food filling up the car
no one has cash to spare and with
inflation at 10 percent we don't need
wage restraint it's time for some profit
restraint
taxpayers helped business with their
bills now it's time for business to play
their part
no layoffs this winter no boardroom
bonanzas and no shareholder sprees
put the cap back on Bankers bonuses
let's have a bigger winful tax on greedy
energy Giants and don't just bail them
out bring them into public ownership
and more protect benefits against
inflation invest in public services and
give us stronger workers rights our
nation of grafters have earned a fair
day's pay for a fair day's work that
means a 15 pound minimum wage as soon as
possible Fair pay agreements to get
wages Rising for everyone and it's time
to do right by the people who've done us
all proud they got us through the
pandemic and we owe them give public
servants a proper pay rise a real pay
rise and give it now
and on November the 2nd from every
corner of the UK we will rally to
Westminster and if the share of a
government is still clinging to Power by
then we will demand that general
election
we are trade unionists just as when the
TUC proposed the furlough scheme at the
start of the pandemic we've got answers
to the problems that Britain faces we've
seen the difference our movement makes
right around the world and from Amazon
to Starbucks growing membership winning
deals proof that solidarity Works backed
up by new laws from Progressive
governments from Spain to New Zealand
and we hope soon Brazil too governments
who know that good jobs and Rising wages
are the route to a decent life
change can come and we can build it
remember those kids remember those kids
who save half their school dinners to
take home for tea remember pension is
too poor to keep warm and workers who
can't afford to get sick while NHS
waiting time saw none of this is
inevitable these are political choices
made by politicians and we can vote them
out
now as unions our job is to win now and
every day the bigger our movement the
stronger we are so informally moving the
general council's statement let's reach
out and tell workers why they should
join unions
you see trade unionism is the reasonable
notion that your boss doesn't have all
the answers that working people together
have a voice and have power and how that
changes everything we are the people who
brought you the weekend the eight hour
day equal pay we're proud of our
diversity our wonderful president Sue
ferns Dr Roach the brilliant who's
brilliantly LED our campaign Against
Racism we stand up for our class
we stand up for our class and it's a
multi-ethnic multi-racial working class
of men and women in cities towns and the
countryside too we're for all working
people yes we've got members on the
railways and shops and factories but
also in Uber deliveroo and Amazon
whatever our background racial religion
everyone deserves a decent job a pension
respect it wasn't wages or workers that
caused this crisis and we refuse to let
workers pay for it people ask me will
the TUC coordinate strike action this
winter and I say we already are
when workers are left with no choice but
to vote for strike action for decent pay
I say bring it on for the last 10 years
I've been proud to lead the TUC and I'm
passing the torch to my comrade the
brilliant poll Novak
at heart I've always believed always
always believed that trade unionism is
about friendship friendship between
workers transforms what is possible
Congress we have hope hoping young
workers joining unions workers backing
workers black workers and white workers
standing together let's take that
message to workplaces and communities in
every corner of the country we can build
a better world we will fight for our
class and together we all win solidarity
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well follow that thank you very much
Francis it's not a time for goodbyes yet
but I do want to say a huge and a
heartfelt thank you from everyone for
all that you've done for the movement in
your time as general secretary
and let's all remember that your
leadership has guided us through
incredibly challenging times austerity
back again brexit pandemic cost of
living crisis and it has been invaluable
so thank you for everything that you've
done genuinely
right Congress we now have to move back
to the four